Hey guys, it's Jan here.
As you know, I really enjoyed the Deadpool
movie and I'm psyched to hear that a sequel
has already been greenlit and is being written
by the same screenwriters.
In this video, I'm going to breakdown Deadpool's
post-credits scenes and talking what it means
for the sequel.
There will be spoilers ahead, so if you're
not ready for that, check out my non-spoiler
review of the movie here!
Deadpool's post-credits is a perfect mix of
tribute to John Hughes's classic 80s comedy
Ferris Bueller's Day Off and sly dig at Marvel's
post-credits scenes, which typically tease
future instalments in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and have featured Samuel L Jackson
as the leather-clad, eye-patch-wearing SHIELD
director Nick Fury at end of Iron Man, Thor,
and Captain America: The First Avenger.
Deadpool's joke that 'Oh, you're expecting
a teaser for Deadpool 2; well, we don't have
that kind of money', again is a crack at not
only Marvel's movies but also other big-budget
PG-13 superhero movies such as the X-Men franchise.
And the influence of Ferris Bueller is obvious
in the look of Deadpool's post-credits in
which our anti-hero dons a Bueller-style dressing
gown, and appears in a room which owes a lot
to the classic comedy thanks to the positioning
of its two doors, the pictures on the wall,
and its flowery wallpaper.
And it's also clear in Deadpool's fourth-wall-breaking
line: 'You're still here!
It's over, go home.'
And later he also tells us to 'Go!', all of
which mimics Ferris Bueller's words, as does
the way Deadpool says them while emerging
from the door and walking towards the camera.
And when Deadpool says 'chika-chika' at the
very end he's imitating the same sound which
appears at the end of Ferris Bueller's post-credits
that's taken from Yello's song 'Oh Yeah'.
Ok, so, in the second part of Deadpool's post-credits
we get the reveal that there's going to be
a sequel featuring the comic book character
Cable.
Deadpool playfully mentions that they're looking
to cast someone, 'a big guy with a flat top,
like Mel Gibson, Dolph Lundgren, or Keira
Knightley'
It's interesting Deadpool mentions Mel Gibson
because the cover of Deadpool #41 is a fantastic
homage to the original Mad Max trilogy in
which Mel Gibson of course played Max.
And the score to the Deadpool movie is by
Junkie XL who also scored Mad Max: Fury Road.
As for Dolph Lundgren, he played The Punisher
in the 1989 movie and The Punisher has appeared
in the Deadpool: Suicide Kings comics.
The Keira Knightley reference, as well as
being a funny joke about her acting range,
could also be a crafty call-back to the fact
she played bounty hunter Domino Harvey in
Tony Scott's 2005 action movie Domino, and
in the Marvel comics there's a female mutant
called Domino who teams up with Cable's mercenary
group Six Pack.
By the way, Deadpool's words, 'Big secret,
shh!', reminded me of the character's appearance
in the post-credits of X-Men Origins: Wolverine,
where we see his severed head breaking the
fourth wall whispering 'shh' to the audience
because at the time no one knows he's still
alive.
There've been rumours and support from fans
for a good while now about having Cable in
the sequel.
Cable's the son of Cyclops and Jean Grey-clone
Madelyne Prior.
He's a time-travelling mutant cyborg with
a cybernetic eye, bionic arms, superhuman
strength, and telepathic and telekinetic powers.
When Deadpool and Cable first meet they're
enemies, but later they team up and even have
their own comic book series together.
In the comics, Cable also established the
X-Force, basically an off-shoot of the X-Men,
so making a sequel with him might be a good
way for Fox to finally get an X-Force movie
off the ground.
Ryan Reynolds has already said that an X-Force
movie is a priority for him.
And Reynolds also posted a teaser video of
him and Olivia Munn who plays Psylocke in
X-Men: Apocalypse, so is he hinting at a potential
Deadpool-Psylocke buddy-up in X-Force?
Going back to character arcs that were left
open in Deadpool, for me I'd love to see Vanessa
get to play her comic book alter ego Copycat.
In the final fight, Vanessa was put in a glass
case like the one Wade was in at the Workshop
and Ajax started suffocating her just as he'd
done to trigger Wade's mutant powers.
As Ajax told Wade, stress activates mutant
genes, so perhaps the stress of falling off
an exploding helicarrier in the glass tank
could have triggered some powers in Vanessa
that we'll see in the next movie.
In the comics, her metamorphic powers are
so strong that she can replicate another mutant's
abilities and their appearance, so she could
be a really interesting character to have
in the X-Men movie universe.
And do you remember Cunningham, the other
patient who Wade talked to at Ajax's workshop?
Well, it's interesting that the film didn't
explicitly seem to kill him off as I think
I saw him being injected and cased up by Angel
Dust later in the movie.
Perhaps Ajax was selling him as a super-soldier
or mutant to someone and we'll see his character
come back?
What do you think?
And remember that Colossus tells Deadpool
that "we'll make an X-Man of you yet", so
perhaps we'll see Deadpool pop up in a future
X-Men movie, or maybe a Gambit or Wolverine
movie?
Now, Garrison Kane was in the original screenplay
for Deadpool but ended up getting cut due
to the movie's tight budget.
Garrison Kane has huge bionic arms and the
filmmakers thought the additional visual effects
required would be too expensive.
But the character does fit in well with Cable
and X-Force in the comics so it would be interesting
to see if he makes it into a sequel.
By the way, Deadpool director Tim Miller has
said he'd love to see Deadpool fight Wolverine's
female clone X23.
After all, there was that funny moment in
the movie where Deadpool had a momentary moral
quandary about attacking some female goons,
debating out loud whether it was more sexist
not to hit them than to actually hit them,
before he got bored and pulled out his gun.
Pitting Deadpool against a female Wolverine
would also get around the fact that Hugh Jackman
has said he wants the next Wolverine movie
to be his last.
So guys what did you think of the post-credits
tease and who would you like to play Cable
in Deadpool 2?
And are there any other X-Men or characters
you'd like to see in the sequel?
I can't wait to read your comments below!
By the way, to check out over 100 more Deadpool
easter eggs & references watch my full Deadpool
Easter Egg video here, and you can also win
some cool Deadpool merch on that video.
And there's also a link here to my full Deadpool
playlist with my review, cool behind-the-scenes
facts about the movie, and Comic Con panel.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!